[Musique]
cidre avec nous il est exactement 20h21
en étant merci on a quatre ont compris
ce que ça voulait dire le direct est ce
que vous êtes sûr de toi
on attend patiemment
en 2001
on avait une petite enceinte bosse
vraiment là c'est assez sérieux sait
rien de prétentieux mais l'ambiance
la jemmerais classé l'armée c'est énorme
qui nous appellent c'est boulot boulot
d'agent ça lui ressemble
gesca but c'est la dure y va avec fundi
sommet entendez vous nous appelez bien
entendu où nous exposer votre problème
on a tout de suite tu as bien damien qui
nous appellent ça lui donne l'amiante
habitat mieux tu nous appelles doux
damien damien salut damien c'est quoi
ton problème
ouais att ouais tu étais au mcdo ouais
t'as voulu ouais ouais ouais je vois le
genre ouais tu essaies de sortir ton de
gates
vous êtes conseiller pôle emploi
exactement et bien vous allez recevoir
beaucoup de chroniqueurs avant l'année
prochaine et a la phobie des rongeurs en
enfer
[Rires]
ce n'est pas vraiment mon genre mais
alors ça pour ceux qui l'ont hélas hélas
j'ai procédé à un premier tirage au sort
où j'appris bris 23 hommes et le balai
devant les boîtes qui se trouve devant
vous donc à 24 boîtes puis j'ai procédé
un second tirage au sort c'est pénible
par les 24 mois et que j'ai mis à votre
disposition donc chacun d'entre eux
voient une boîte au hasard et bien sûr
cyril ne connais pas le contenu des
boîtes seule la pince mon ami le
banquier connaît le contenu des boîtes
merci ya un grand trou n 10 qui va se
jouer là dès ce week end je vois les
joueurs
moi je voulais dire citypass benoît
paire un ami richard gasquet je suis pas
dedans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle m'appelle phrase allah karim zéribi
qui me manque de ballons sont restés
sourds à ces le gouvernement sont restés
sous un monde je descends les jeunes
sont dans la rue sont reste sourd de
trois sommes le 4 janvier que fait le
gouvernement
ils sont restés sourds c'est scandaleux
moi quand je vois la ligne marseille
angoulême depuis plus de 42 minutes qui
permet qu'a fait le gouvernement c'est
qu'il faut rester sourd claude je
voudrais dire coach je suis un
compétiteur je les adore le sport est
franchement tu es un modèle combes
séance et je voulais te dire et je sais
que tu fais des treks franchement
comique si un jour tu veux qu'on parte
en vacances ensemble
moi je te suis au boulot tu me vois
comme vacances des vacances roots et des
vacances à beyrouth
ensemble on part comme ça que tu sais
pas
franchement je viens comme info sien on
est on est complet la mairie et la
recevoir vous d'en bal on se trompe on
arrive à peine à way ah oui mais là ça
oui vous l'avez invitée ou pas je pose
on va l'on va on va essayer de la vie
derrière ready de mardi s'ils savaient
qu'elle va venir ça c'est sûr parce que
je pense que et et pour on va voir si
elle a le courage de venir mario vote
parce qu'elle va être bousculé quand
même avec toute l'équipe qui a je vous
rappelle l'année prochaine balances ton
pote et l'équipe de foot ou encore voilà
autorise à table qu'a fait le
gouvernement
il faut rester sourd
[Musique]